I want to ask you though this is a
question that always gets Heat
what bothers me is that first of all I
do think that women oftentimes have a
lot of expectations of men and then when
you ask them well what is it okay for
men to expect of you they just say well
I take care of myself I look good and
it's like well what else Honey what else
Beyond looking good because it's not all
about appearance that's number one and
also oh shitty women you've got to get
to this why do guys give time to women
who don't deserve it what kind of
message is that sent like is it just
they're using the girls why why give
them time at all if there's a girl out
there who's not high value who's
promiscuous you know you're not going to
want to bring that girl home to Mom yeah
why are you giving her time what kind of
message that's sent into the real nice
girl in the wings so that's a great
question and to me it's the same kind of
message that's being sent to the women
who was given the crappy guy the time
the attention and effort yeah the
fundamental reality of life is we just
have to be honest you know this is
there's this um scene in Aladdin one of
my favorite movies when jafar's
character was talking to Aladdin and he
said Aladdin have you heard of The
Golden Rule he's like what's the Golden
Rule he said whoever has the gold makes
the rules yeah that's the Golden Rule
and so what I realized is whoever
whoever the gold is symbolic to many
different things but right but let's say
the gold is power Whoever has the power
Whoever has a value makes rules so if
somebody has a level of attraction
we allow them to do whatever they want
and that's the sad thing about Society
it's a level of privilege that these
individuals have right so I can give you
a quick story
I remember there was there was a young
lady who I knew and she was a beautiful
woman
but she was the rudest person on this
planet
and you sit down and you see like why
why were why are you like this because
in her world she learned that I can be
as rude as I want and I can still get
whatever I want is it's like you're a
parent you know this yes imagine if
every time your son you know threw his
food on the floor and got a temper
tantrum you gave him a cookie every time
he didn't clean up his bed you gave him
a a a lollipop and then eventually do
that for all his life and his brain he's
like I can do whatever I want and still
good things are going to happen to me
what is incentivizing me from doing
what's right yeah so unfortunately what
happens is you have a whole community of
women as well as men who have their
whole life had been incentivized to do
whatever they want and people still give
them attention you think about like um
like some of these I forgot what's the
name of the Hollywood actress Tyler if
you can look it up it's a Hollywood
actress who got married seven or eight
times I forgot her name I think it might
be Elizabeth something but Hollywood
actors in 1930s and 50s she got married
like seven times
how can you get how what kind of think
about the guy number five who married
her I think about the guy number six
yeah number like did you not see the
first fourth time but she was just so
attractive she was so desirable people
dealt with her nonsense and so to me
that's one of the biggest things that I
saw in society is that you found it was
a potato Elizabeth Taylor I knew it was
Elizabeth Taylor yeah yeah oh yeah like
yo but she was so beautiful dudes would
put up with her over and over and over
again I saw the picture Marilyn Monroe
outside the same way like you couldn't
do whatever you want and so that's
unfortunately what happens when you have
a certain level of attraction you have a
certain level of value to opposite sex
and they don't care you can do whatever
you want you can spit on them and call
them they can be rude for them they will
give you time they will give you energy
they'll give you if their men will
definitely give you money and so
unfortunately it's a whole community of
women who pregnant on men like that and
they take advantage of men like that and
and to me my biggest beef is like why
are the men incentivizing that that's
always my argument you incentive is what
you want to see more if you are a mom
you know this when I was a preschool
teacher we taught this you got to
celebrate what you want to see more of
in this world if you're constantly
giving all these half naked girls views
and going on their only fans and
watching them on pornography how do you
expect the Next Generation to not do
these things so oh that's my challenge
is like they're talking about high value
women and what I hear them saying is
someone who respects a woman who
respects herself a woman who wants to be
a good mom a woman who is supportive and
respectful and caring and keeps a
beautiful home and values those things
and is intelligent and I hear all of
these characteristics and I'm like okay
if that's high value how is that high
value woman gonna feel if you're
spending your time and your money and
your energy catering to a woman who
doesn't have any of those things and
instead is just sleeping around with you
and six other guys on the side and I
understand like men are hardwired for
sex I understand for them sometimes it's
just about the sex but that that's not
the message that that high value woman
out there is getting 100 and that's and
that's to me is where I'm going back to
Solutions when you genuinely don't care
about Solutions you're not thinking the
way you and I are thinking when you're
genuinely trying to create solutions to
society you say I don't care how
hardwired you are to sex that is
creating an unhealthy message you are
contributing to the problem in society
as much as you complain about the only
fans girl the girls on on Instagram
models and all that stuff you are
contributing to the unhealthy behaviors
so yes you're 100 right as a man you
need to have that hard line but in their
worlds they'll go to the strip clubs
they'll pay for the escorts they'll go
overseas and deal with the prostitutes
they're like well it's just we're just
men and like you don't realize you are
there is a Marketplace if there was no
Marketplace that meant if there was no
men spending money doing this she
couldn't do this if she open to only
fans and she only got 15 guess what
she'll get her but off the couch and get
a real job and actually contribute to
society instead of pushing out that
toxicity but unfortunately there's a
whole community of men the same men that
talk about we want a high value women
are the same men lining these women's
pockets and then you want to complain
about women today you can't have it both
ways either either incentivize what you
want to see in the world don't pay for
the only fans don't be sleeping around
with these unhealthy women don't be
giving them any attention because the
currency especially for women is
attention don't give them a single lick
of attention or you go ahead and and
understand this is the world we live in
don't whine about the world we live in
and do your thing but you can't have it
both ways and men and women both want to
have it both ways if you want to watch
the full episode click right here and if
you want to ask me a question talk
one-on-one send me a FaceTime video join
a video with a group of your friends and
me you gotta download manect and you
gotta join me there it's gonna be really
hot
thank you